no man sky is a game that doesn't hold
your hand leaving many of its systems
for you to discover for yourself which
is half the fun still you can
potentially waste so much time and money
at the start that there are some things
we wish we knew when we first started
playing like these things let's start
with getting some of that easy money
catalog everything analyze a planet's
flora and fauna and report your
discoveries for a steady stream of quick
cash those animals aren't just for
cataloguing and murdering though feeding
animals will make them happy and lead
you to some rare minerals so did he just
poop that out or I mean where did that
come yeah I'm still digging it
now when exploring a planet remember to
plan ahead with resources and equipment
make sure you have enough resources to
keep your multi-tool exosuit and
starship charged before landing on a
planet if you happen to not have enough
plutonium for your launch thrusters for
example it is entirely possible to land
on a planet with zero plutonium and then
you're stuck and your only choice is to
kill yourself and load the last save
inventory management is actually a
pretty big deal in this game and can be
a pain at the beginning especially when
you don't have that many slots you'll
hear this phrase a lot a good trick is
to transfer secondary and valuable
resources back to your ship when
traveling on foot your starship storage
holds twice as many resources as the
exosuit slots just remember that you can
send anything to your ship no matter
where you are but if you want to
retrieve it from your ship you have to
be nearby it
speaking of which you want to be mindful
of the distance from your starship when
exploring on foot rather than walking
four minutes to explore or reach a point
of interest consider flying there it's
an added step but it saves time and
negates the need of constantly having to
backtrack to your ship now if you've
already messed up and are horribly far
away from your ship some outposts have
these devices that when given a bypass
ship will call your ship to you
did you know that planes fly faster the
higher they are up in the atmosphere
that signs right there and it also
applies to no man's sky if your
destination on the planet is further
away fly up until you can see the
curvature of the planet you'll notice
that the destination timer is now much
smaller again science another important
thing you want to do as soon as possible
is get yourself a fancy new multi-tool
and make sure you pick one with plenty
of slots don't spend too much time
upgrading a multi-tool that doesn't have
that many slaps especially your first
one it's garbage don't waste your time
when entering a new system the first
thing you should do is head right to the
space station the Galactic trade
terminal there will tell you how much
elements are worth in the system
compared to the galactic average see
these ones with the stars on them these
are the ones for the best market price
and are what you want to spend your time
mining while in the system and the best
way to find the valuable elements in the
system is to follow trade routes see
these trails in the sky follow those and
they will lead you to a whole cache of
valuables the terminal isn't the only
way to trade though all the other ships
in the hangar are full of space traders
with their own values some of these guys
are collectors for ancient artifacts and
these are the ones you want to sell your
relics to
these traders will also sell you their
ships but don't jump the gun and buy one
right away you can actually find a new
ship through transmissions which are
available on every planet it's
definitely a luck of the draw but it
does be dropping upwards to 300,000
units
and finally once you get the warp drive
working go to an Atlas station ASAP
they're marked as red on the map you
will get an item that is critical where
I couldn't spoil this one but trust us
you want it and there you go that is a
bunch of tips and tricks that we wish we
knew when we started no man's sky have
any hot tips that you've discovered
please share them in the comments below
and for even more videos on no man's sky
stay tuned to GameSpot